SONAM SAXENA: Hey, guys.
Good morning.
Thank you for being here.
Despite all the
partying last night,
I'm glad to see people
bright and early
for the cloud native
resource management breakout.
Before we get started, let's do
a brief round of introductions.
Greg.
GREGG DONOVAN: Hi,
I'm Greg Donovan.
I'm a staff software engineer
at Etsy where I work on search.
I've been at Etsy
for nine years.
SONAM SAXENA: Michael.
MICHAEL KIBBE: Hello,
my name's Michael Kibbe.
I'm a software engineer on
the cloud native resource
management team here at Google.
SONAM SAXENA: And my
name is Sonam Saxena,
and I'm a product
manager at Google.
I support the Cloud
Deployment Manager team,
which is the team
behind the product
that we are going to
be unveiling today.
I've been in various PM
roles for about 16 years now.
And I'm relatively
new to Google--
so about nine months in.
Before we get started,
let's get a bit
of housekeeping out of the way.
I would highly recommend
opening up the Cloud Next
app on your phone.
The app allows you to
ask and upvote questions.
It's super easy to use.
Just look for cloud native
resource management session.
Click on the Dory Q&A button
and start asking or upvoting
questions that other in
the audience are asking.
To get you warmed
up, I've actually
thrown up a question
on Dory for Greg
because I love to help him.
And so without
further delay, let's
get started and talk about
what we are covering today.
We are announcing a new
product, config connector
And we are really excited
to tell you all about it.
Config connector is going
to allow you to use QCUtil
to manage your GCP resources.
We are going to give
your familiar old QCUtil
new superpowers.
How?
We are going to tell you and
show you later in the talk.
Our goal is for you to
have one CI/CD pipeline
that you deal with on a day to
day basis, the one that drives
all your QCUtil invocations.
But as I tell my kids, you
have to eat your vegetables
before you can eat dessert.
And to get everyone in the
audience on the same page,
I'm going to start with a
bit of a history lesson.
I'm specifically going to
be talking about two secular
trends, adoption of
infrastructure as code
and the rise of Kubernetes.
And then I'm going to
talk about the problems
that we see because of
that stacking and then dive
into the solution
that we are building.
We will then shift gears and
get into the exciting part
of the presentation.
Greg has an explosive
demo lined up for us,
and he's going to
talk through how
Etsy has adopted GCP
and his experience
around using the
product, obviously.
And then we'll end
with Gabby, Greg and I
taking questions from the
Dory and from the audience.
If that sounds good, let's
start with something a customer
told me last year.
So as you're reading
this, remember
this is a company that the vast
majority of people in this room
probably use, or at
least have heard of.
I've redacted their name
as getting legal approval
in time for next
consult on [INAUDIBLE]..
So to put this in context, this
company is forward leaning.
They have infrastructure
on prem, on GKE on GCP.
But given that
GKE is declarative
and GCP is imperative,
they run into the problem
of fragmented management
language matrix.
So how did we end up all here?
To understand that, let's
talk about the first secular
trend that has taken
the world by storm--
the adoption of
infrastructure as code.
It seems like a lifetime away.
But only a few years back,
many of us in this room
were still doing
configuration by hand.
How well has public
cloud provider
have achieved
multiple 9 reliability
on our infrastructure.
Increasingly errors
are not caused
because of hardware problems,
but because somebody's fat
fingered an extra zero,
pressed the wrong button.
For the most part, we can all
agree that manual configuration
is mostly behind us.
And the advantage of
putting everything in Git
is tremendous.
Once you have
everything in Git--
and you can start applying
basically the last 30
years of software
management best
practices to these resources.
And you can start
treating infrastructure
as zeros and ones and
leveraging Git workforce to do
some very interesting things.
Let me give you three examples
of what I've seen customers do.
The first example
is approval flaws
in highly regulated environment.
So if you're working
at a startup,
you may laugh at this, that some
companies have to get approval
from their VP or
directors of IT before you
can approve spending
on infrastructure
at a certain level.
How would finance, insurance,
government, health care,
being able to leverage Git
workforce for approvals
is not only a
nice-to-have feature,
but it's a regulatory
requirement.
Another great example is the
notion of pre submit check.
GCP recently erased a perk
called config validator--
it's an EAP--
that allows you to ensure that
your policies and structure
articulated in code
are not in violation
with their overall
automation policies.
So imagine a scenario
where you spin up
a Cloud Function for a few
seconds, config validator--
ensure that the function is
compliant, saving you hours
of rework or even worse later.
And my last example is
my favorite, code reds.
Not that I like code reds,
but it's a good example.
I met a customer
last year in New York
who has a pre agreed
template on who gets access
to water resources in case
of a code red scenario,
if something bad really happens.
And she is able to give
hundreds of engineers
access to GCP environments in
case something bad happens.
Additionally, because this
is now part of a code drive
that her leadership
has agreed upon,
she is able to simulate a
coded drill, giving developers
the access they need to fix
the issues that they are seeing
and to roll back the
access once a fix has
been formed and deployed.
And the best part of this story
is that you don't have to be FC
or snap to take advantage
of these dev ops practices.
Fortune 500 companies,
government agencies
are adopting these
workflows so that they
can recover from failure
faster, deploy more often,
and deploy more quickly.
And all of this has
been really exciting.
As in the last few
years, many startups
and established players
have entered into the fray
and trying to simplify
how you manage and deploy
infrastructure.
As I see this, this kind of
happening in three waves.
I started with CI/CD for
code, which is now pretty well
established and you have a
lot of options to choose from.
Then configured code came in
as part of the second wave
with Google's Cloud Deployment
Manager, CHEF, Pulumi,
Terraform leading the way.
And everything for code
is starting to take off,
but customers wanted to put
their own policies, router
configurations, firewall rules,
VPCs, everything into Git.
And with all these
different tools and services
in the space, customers
have a broad set
of options and standards and
languages to choose from.
And often, these
options and standards
do not work well
with each other.
But we'll talk about
that a bit later.
For now, let's
shift gear and talk
about the next secular trend
that I have been observing--
the rise and adoption
of Kubernetes.
For many of you in this
room, this is not news.
However, given the
diversity of the audience--
and let me quickly talk to
some publicly available data
and what is driving the
adoption of Kubernetes.
Over the first few years,
we have seen Kubernetes
steadily gaining in
usage on every platform.
But nowhere has it been
more popular than on GCP.
As most of you are aware,
Kubernetes was originally
developed at Google.
And we continue to lead the
innovation in the space.
According to a
survey by Datadog,
organizations running
containers in GCP, more than 85%
orchestrate workloads
with Kubernetes.
In Azure, which has
offered a manage Kubernetes
service for about two
years now, roughly 65%
of organizations
in using containers
are also using Kubernetes.
Kubernetes is
neutrally everywhere.
Our customers run their
own Kubernetes clusters
and diverse infrastructure
environments.
And all three major
cloud providers
offer to manage Kubernetes
service as well.
So what is driving this adoption
and just to get into that like,
hey, what is driving this,
think back in the day
to when you're to
update software
or when you're
pushing a deployment.
There's usually a
lot of downtime.
And I remember doing my
organizational wide upgrades
at midnight or over
the weekend when
user traffic was at a minimum.
Continuously deploying
new features with downtime
does not increase velocity.
The goal is to update
the application
without any downtime, as your
users expect a constant uptime.
Therefore, velocity is made
through a number of features
you could ship per hour
while still maintaining
a highly of level service.
The core concepts of Kubernetes
which enable high velocity
at immutability
decorative configuration
and self-feeling system.
So as far as the
developers are concerned,
they apply the configuration in
Kubernetes using QCUtil apply.
And they can focus on
higher level functions
and not worry about downtime.
Also as your products
grows, you have
to scale both your software
and use working on it.
So Kubernetes
achieve scalability
by favoring decouple
microservice architectures.
In a decoupled
architecture, each component
is separated from
other components
by defined APIs and
service load balances.
APIs provides a buffer between
implementer and consumer
and/or balances provide
a buffer between running
instances of a service.
Decoupling components while
lower balances makes it easier
to scale the
program that make up
your service because increasing
the size of the program
can be done without
adjusting or reconfiguring
any of the other
layers of your service.
Let's talk about
suppression of concern.
This topic should resonate
really well with you.
When Google builds a service,
as a consumer of their service,
you don't really
care about how we
go about building that service.
Similarly, in Kubernetes,
the application developer
relies on the SLA delivered by
the continual orchestration API
without worrying about
how it is achieved.
And likewise, the orchestration
API reliability engineer
focuses on delivering
the orchestration API SLA
without having to worry
about the applications that
run on top of it.
This separation, or
decoupling, means
that a small team running
a Kubernetes cluster
can be responsible for
supporting thousands
of teams running on
their application
within that cluster.
And finally, because in
Kubernetes applications
can be co-located
on the same machine
without impacting
each other, this
means that tasks
from multiple users
can be packed tightly
onto fewer machines.
This in turns provides
a greater efficiency
and also reduces the
cost of hardware,
as less machines are used, which
means better cost efficiencies.
So now that we are
on the same page,
let's talk about a managed
configuration before Kubernetes
arrived on the scene.
Most organizations picked
an orchestrator of choice.
So they could have
Jenkins or a Git of choice
that they worked out of.
Depending upon which
customer I am talking to,
they will often have
separate organization
managing their policies
versus their infrastructure.
It's not necessary that,
within the same organization--
especially if it's large--
they agree on the
same choice of tools
on both sides of the house.
They will then couple
their orchestrator
with one or more client
that does the actuation.
And they may end up using Cloud
Deployment Manager, Pulumi,
or Terraform for
their GCP resources
and help for Kubernetes.
This stacking and
mixing of tools
has led to this fragmented
management and language matrix
that I talked about where
developers and operators have
to use a Rube
Goldbergish set of tools
to manage different resources
type with different providers.
The challenges is that any
two organizations today
are not using these
tools in a similar way.
And often they're confusing
inconsistencies across UIs,
developing an
environment, command lines
as decays configuration
tools and docks,
leading to increased opportunity
for customers to make an error.
As you can imagine,
this can often
lead to workflows that
can be hard to orchestrate
across non interoperable tools
that speak different languages.
But wait, there is more.
As Kubernetes
gaining wide option,
increasingly customers have
to operate in the weird split
brain mode.
When you're managing
your Kubernetes cluster,
you have this clean
decorative language
where you order what you want.
It's like ordering pizza.
You say medium
pepperoni, extra cheese,
and the pizza shows up magically
in your doorstep in 30 minutes.
However, when you're
managing your legacy cloud,
you have to use imperative apps
with conflicting standards.
Now you have to be precise and
described the entire recipe
step by step.
So if all you wanted
was a database
on top of a sequel
running low on a VM,
you have to go step
by step and you have
to say, hey, spin up the VM.
Then, you pull the thing.
You wait for a couple of
minutes for the VM to come up.
Then you're like, oh,
populate a sequel database.
And then the sequel
database comes up.
You pull it, and
then you're like,
oh, you put the
database inside it.
And you have to basically
ensure that every step was
completed successfully before
you can do the next step.
This creates cognitive
dissonance for our customers,
and we decide to step in
and solve the problem.
Config connector is
a Kubernetes plugin
that allows the
resources implemented
by non-Kubernetes APIs to be
managed declaratively using
Kubernetes native
configuration and tooling.
Users express their
declarative intent
for config connector resources
as a [INAUDIBLE] YAML
configuration, which can then
be applied to a GKE cluster,
just like any other
Kubernetes source.
The config connector
processes that the declared
intent to the state of the
underlying resource, typically
non declared and defined and
managed, and materializes it
through calls to
the underlying API.
Config connector also manages
the resources over time
by continuously deconsign
the actual state
of the underlying resource
with declarative intent.
So what does that mean to you?
So there are three
major advantages.
Firstly, conflict
actor will make
all GCP resources behave as if
they were Kubernetes resources.
So now your
developers don't have
to learn multiple
competing languages
to manage their infrastructure.
It's just a single
config.YAML file
and containing all
infrastructure as code.
And you QCUtil apply by the
single config YAML file.
Secondly, you achieve
separation of concerns
with eventual consistency.
As a customer of GCP
using config connector,
you do not really have
to care about how Google
achieves the desired state.
You can ask config connector
to spin up a database
and populate data in it.
And for some reason, if we
try to populate the data first
a non instant database,
config connector
will gracefully back off,
wait for the database
to spin up, and then populate
the database once things
are up and ready.
And finally, because
config connector
is relying on Kubernetes server
as a source of [INAUDIBLE],,
the infrastructure
spun up a self-feeling.
So if a miscarrier
intern comes in
and fat fingered the
spanner, config connector
will notice the
drift and correct it.
To showcase all
of this and more,
I'm going to ask Greg to talk us
through the next set of slides.
GREGG DONOVAN: Excellent.
Thank you.
So I am, as I said,
Greg Donovan from Etsy.
And for the last
18 months or so,
I've been working
on our migration
to GKE as part of Etsy's
larger GCP migration from our
on prem, co-located
bare metal centers.
And I'm looking forward to
sharing some of our lessons
migrating from bare
metal to GKE and how
config connector fits in.
So what is Etsy?
Etsy is the global marketplace
for unique and creative goods.
It's a large international and
rapidly growing marketplace.
We're constantly trying
to improve the product
to keep up with our
buyers and sellers' needs,
making development
velocity paramount.
Search at Etsy,
which I worked on,
is an especially fun problem.
It combines large scale
systems and machine
learning problems,
real world impact,
and lots of interesting
products to think about.
Etsy's headquarters is in
Brooklyn, where it was founded.
And we also have
engineering offices here
in San Francisco, in
Toronto, Dublin, and plenty
of remotes around the world.
Etsy started in 2005,
before the cloud.
And from 2005 to 2017, all
the company's search services
ran in our co-located
data centers.
Till 2016, everything was
pure bare metal servers--
no VMs, no containers.
Then in 2016, we built our
first on prem Kubernetes cluster
and began migrating our
search applications over time
to Kubernetes.
In 2017, the company
decided to move to GCP.
Our on prem Kubernetes
migration morphed
into a GKE migration, which
we finished up this spring.
When we started
our GCP migration,
we decided to use Terraform to
provision our GCP resources.
We used Terraform
for everything,
except for our applications
and the Kubernetes
objects that they create.
So what is Terraform?
For those unfamiliar,
Terraform is a framework
for provisioning
cloud resources using
a declarative configuration
language called HCL.
In addition to GCP, it
supports the AWS, Azure,
other infrastructure providers
via their plugin framework.
Underneath Terraform
represents our resources
as a graph with
their dependencies.
When you make
Terraform changes, it
needs to reconcile your declared
state with the actual state
of these resources.
For example, does that the
GKE cluster name search exist?
Does it have the node
pools we've requested?
And if there is the drift
between your desired
state and the current
state, Terraform
will figure out
which API calls it
needs to make in
order to reconcile
the desired and actual state.
And if you're interested
in learning more
about the underlying
graph at work,
there's a great talk called
applying graph theory
to infrastructure as code
that I've found very helpful.
And to deploy
Terraform changes, we
have a CI pipeline that
uses Jenkins, validates
that a Terraform
change is valid,
gives you the output
from a Terraform plan,
and then, if a human approves
the plan, applies it.
We have a single
Terraform monorepo
with all the company's
cloud infrastructure giving
a single place to audit,
refactor, and a single CI/CD
pipeline for all of us.
Now over in GKE,
where search is,
Kubernetes does
something very similar.
Our declared state is in
our YAML configuration.
The actual state is
determined by Kubernetes,
usually by consulting the Etsy
D database that backs its API.
New call kubectl
apply, Kubernetes dates
will begin to reconcile
what you expressed
that you wanted in YAML with
what's actually in existence.
So both Terraform and
Kubernetes have graphs
with a notion of dependencies.
Each graph knows how to
do a topological sort,
figure out what the order
that it should apply changes.
The Kubernetes API
is a wonderful thing.
We're able to express
our infrastructure richly
with an API that works
on any cloud provider
on prem, et cetera.
And we have assembled built
in Kubernetes objects,
like deployment staples
sets, et cetera,
that can model our
infrastructure declaratively.
We also take advantage of the
Kubernetes extension mechanism,
custom resource definitions,
to model objects
at a higher level.
For example, we use
the Prometheus Operator
to deploy Prometheus.
It uses a set of custom
resource definitions
to model objects that
are the core abstractions
in the Prometheus installation--
Prometheus, AlertManager,
ServiceMonitors,
and PrometheusRules.
These then become top
level objects in Kubernetes
that we can manipulate
with kubectl.
So I can do kubectl
get service monitors
and see a list of
directives for Prometheus
about what to scrape.
CRDs make a lot of sense
when you analogize them
to programming languages.
If pods, services,
config maps, et cetera
are like your primitive types,
custom resource definitions
allow you to build higher
level abstractions out
of these primitives.
They're like Java classes
but for Kubernetes.
And Kubernetes has, to quote
Kelsey Hightower "become
the POSIX API for
distributed systems."
And so at Etsy, we deploy all
of our search services to GKE.
We use the tech stack on this
slide for our Kubernetes CI/CD
pipeline, which we'll see
more of in the upcoming demo.
Suffice it to say, we've
invested a huge amount
of time and effort to make this
pipeline as fast and powerful
as we can.
It offers speedy incremental
reproducible builds
using Bazel, especially for
incremental docker container
layer builds and
programmatic control
using Python over the Kubernetes
YAML generated specifically
for each environment.
And our goal is
to make deploying
to Kubernetes fast, reliable,
as customizable as you
need to be, and as
simple as we can make it.
We want our search
repo to be the one
place you need to make changes
to launch a new feature
or create a brand new testing
environment in, for example,
a PR driven workflow.
So if this seems intriguing,
I gave a talk at BazelCon
last year about this stack.
And I'll be speaking
more about it
at CouCon in
Barcelona next month.
Or just email me.
Unfortunately, this stack
has a glaring weakness.
Anytime you want to make
changes to GCP growth resources,
it doesn't help us.
Our two worlds,
Terraform and Kubernetes,
do not interact
easily, adding lots
of friction, fragility, and
complexity to the development
process.
Config connector is designed
to solve this problem.
So let's show config connector
in action in a real setting.
I'd like to show you
two examples at Etsy
that we targeted for which
config connector could
make our day to day
development easier.
So as I noted,
search is organized
into a large monorepo built
with the Bazel build tool.
Since I can't open
source our entire code
base for legal reasons, I
created a demo app on GitHub
that serves as a
microcosm of our code
base with a whittled
down version of much
of the scaffolding that we use
in this Kubernetes delivery
pipeline.
So you can see it here on GitHub
if you want to pull it up.
And the demo is going to
show off two issues that we
targeted for config connector.
The first is how to
debug a problematic JVM.
So for JVM diagnostics, we
used the YourKit profiler
with its detailed CPU memory
and event snapshot files.
And on an application
exit, we are seeing them
from a pod local
directory to a GCS bucket.
And we wanted the
GCS bucket names
to be dynamic based on their
environment, some combination
of the GKE cluster,
the namespace,
the pod name so the snapshots
were well organized,
didn't step on
each other's toes.
The second issue we wanted
config connector to help with
is structured logging.
So for certain use cases,
we'd like to stream
logs directly to BigQuery so
that we can perform analytics
on them.
And again, we want a dynamic
one to one mapping of data
set to application environment.
Before config
connector, we would
need to go to
Terraform every time
we created a new environment.
So if you imagine that PR
driven workflow where you've
got some changes
you want to make,
before actually going to search
and deploying your changes,
you've got to go
over to Terraform.
And you've got to follow
all of these steps.
And there might be
some I've forgotten.
And what makes it more
difficult is that, for example,
for a GCS bucket
that you might want
to create for your namespace,
we have random slugs attached
to them for security reasons.
And then Terraform state
files are encrypted.
So it adds a lot of steps.
And another problem is
Terraform's configuration
language.
It's very, very limited.
It makes a complex real
world configuration
like we have at
Etsy very difficult.
For example, a simple
for loop over a map
is almost impossible to
do without reading a blog
post about it in Terraform.
Ah, we're not up to that.
So let's go to the demo.
So this is the script
we're going to run.
It's the main method of our
pod that starts up a server.
And then when it
exits, it copies all
of these snapshot files to GCS.
And here is the service itself.
It sets up BigQuery.
It sets up some URL handlers,
writes to our structure logs,
can say hello and goodbye,
just a simple application
to show how this works.
And then this is
the script that gets
called on shutdown to write
those snapshots to the GSC.
And we can also show the
structured log, which
is writing rows to BigQuery.
And here is how we
use Python and Bazel
to generate dynamic YAML
that we sent to Kubernetes.
So for example, this
target is called subtargets
that generate a dynamic
namespace, a dynamic GCS
bucket, a dynamic BigQuery
data set, and then
our regular
Kubernetes deployment.
Now this is not the
most dynamic example.
But if you imagine
QA environments
versus test environments,
different things you might want
to be testing, So this is
just a Python with PyYAML,
generating a standard
Kubernetes deployment
based on your context--
what's your namespace, what's
your cluster, et cetera.
So this is the application.
Here is the service
that it uses.
But the more
interesting part comes
when config connector comes in.
So here is how we
create a GCS bucket.
So there's no switching
over to Terraform.
We're using a CRD--
so the config connector
CRD right here.
And now we get a new type inside
of our Kubernetes cluster.
We have a type called
storage bucket,
and that is provided
by config connector
that Sonam announced today.
And you can see we set up the
standard GCS bucket attributes,
its lifecycle, when it gets
deleted, after how long,
et cetera.
And then we do the
same for BigQuery.
So we dynamically create
a BigQuery data set.
We follow the BigQuery
whoops for how
you have to name your
data sets, set up
the table expiration, a
friendly name, et cetera.
And then we've got this new
kind within our data set,
a BigQuiery data set.
So we've got these
new super powers.
And I'll show you
one last bit, which
is how we generate the
underlying docker container.
So it's a Bazel
container image target.
It takes a base docker
container, adds some scripts,
adds the YourKit files,
and outputs a docker image.
So let's show it to work.
So let's see.
We're in the CNRM GCP
next 19 demo namespace.
That's where we want to be.
Let's see.
And do we have anything running?
We don't.
So we're going to
hit that target
that we showed
before that's going
to deploy all of those things.
So we're going to try to
deploy it in one command--
the namespace, the
deployment, the service,
and the BigQuery data set,
and the GCS bucket-- so again,
something that will require
previously multiple trips
over to Terraform to
generate these things,
cut and pasted
into our code base.
But now it's one command.
Here goes.
There we go.
So we created the namespace.
We configured the GCS bucket.
Now we can see these
things in action.
So now we do have a pod.
And we can go say hi to it.
So let's first see that
it's up and running.
OK, listening on port 8,000.
Let's go say hi.
So we'll set up port forwarding.
So now we have a port
forward from my laptop
to the pod running
inside of GKE.
And we can curl it to say hello.
Excellent.
And now we should
be able to see,
did it actually create
those storage buckets.
Well, it shouldn't
actually-- yeah,
so there's the storage bucket.
And we can see
that the underlying
CRD has been created.
So let's describe it.
And you can see the control
loop in the background.
It says it's up to date.
So given the YAML
we have here where
we described what we wanted.
We wanted a storage bucket
with these parameters
deleted after seven days.
And there's a control loop
in the background making sure
that those GCS resources matches
what we had in the YAML spec.
And we could see the same thing
with the BigQuery data set.
And there it is.
BigQuery data set exists,
as we wanted it to.
But if we go to
the console, now we
can see these resources
right in the console.
And there they are.
So the storage bucket exists.
We can go over to BigQuery.
Really, we did just create a
new data set just with cube CTL.
And that's there.
And there's our logs table.
And we should have
some data in it.
And there we go.
So, when we said hello, it
wrote the hello message.
So it's working.
And now, when we
shut it down, it
should write those GCS snapshots
to the dynamically created
bucket--
a very dramatic goodbye.
So let's see if that
actually worked.
It's listed out.
Look at that.
So those are the
logs and snapshots.
So when the JVM exited,
it wrote these snapshots
to the GCS bucket.
And so all of this that
would have required you
know multiple
trips to Terraform,
lots of configuration, now
it's one cube CTL command,
which is very exciting.
So the demo's worked so far.
Should we push our luck and
try something a little crazier?
Let's make a new
test environment.
So what should we call
our new test environment?
Let's call it Michael.
So we have this single
source of truth configuration
for all of our applications,
their namespaces, et cetera.
So here is where we
defined previously
the namespace that we
wanted to have in the app
that we were deploying, our
example app, in which cluster
we wanted it to have it.
So now we're going to make a
new namespace that didn't exist.
So this is a Bazel.bzl
file that is defining this.
We'll call it Michael.
I'll call it Michael test.
So let's find the
dynamically created targets.
So there's five targets.
We have a new one for
each of those things
that we deployed previously
to the other namespace.
And we'll deploy them to
the Michael namespace.
It's a real demo.
We're pushing our luck.
So now it's going
to generate YAML
with the new context this time,
the Michael test namespace.
And it's going to the new
namespace, the new GCS buckets,
the new BigQuery data
set, the new service,
the new deployment.
And let's actually switch
over to that namespace.
And the one thing
that's manual right now
is getting the proper
credentials in there.
That is something that, with
workload identity that's
being announced shortly, this
manual step will go away.
So we put the credentials
that our pods need.
And now let's see
if we have pods.
We do.
And so if we go over
here again, now we
should see a new BigQuery data
set dynamically created just
for this namespace.
Let's cross our fingers.
And there it is.
There's the Michael
test data set.
And that's up and going, and
we should see the GCS buckets.
And there we are.
So a dynamically
created test environment
with a single command--
so imagine this in the context
of a PR driven workflow.
You have an engineer on the
team who wants testing changes.
This is the fastest path to
getting a new test environment
minted out with
your parameters that
involve Kubernetes
infrastructure and GCP
infrastructure.
You can now do it in a single
command, what would previously
have taken two CI/CD pipelines,
different approval steps,
et cetera, et cetera--
can now be done
just with cube CTL.
So that is pretty
exciting for us.
Now back to Sonam.
SONAM SAXENA: That was amazing.
Thank you, Greg.
Can we switch back
to the-- oh, perfect.
Magic.
So that was amazing.
Let's move on to
the Q&A section.
I'll ask Michael
to come up on stage
as we get set up over here.
Greg, you don't get any rest.
For people that
arrived a bit late,
I would suggest downloading
the Cloud Next app.
The app allows you to ask
questions and upvote questions
in the audience.
It's super easy to use.
Also before we get
started, if you
would like to
participate in our Alpha,
please check us out on GitHub.
It's a closed offer.
We have limited capacity.
So I would suggest
getting on this quickly.
Also, if you hate typing, just
point your Android or iPhone
camera to the QR code.
You should see a pop
up on your camera
that takes you to that page.
All we need is the email of
the user or service account
that you'll be using to
run config connector.
And we can get you
up and running.
With that, let's go to the Dory.
And Michael, the floor is yours.
[MUSIC PLAYING]